all right well like i said we're gonna
be going over the check over variation
tonight going through some uh
some example games uh and
we'll get right into it so for those of
you who do not know
the checkover sicilian starts with e4 c5
so here's our normal sicilian defense
and normally whites will go knight f3
opting to go into an open variation
now the checkover comes from this move
d6 so this is not the
only move for black that's a sicilian
there's
plenty of other moves knight c6 e6
knight f6
g6 all of these are playable but the
checkover
comes from d6 after d6
there is pawn d4
which is again opening up the position
and almost always black will take this
pawn
and the reason is they're giving up this
um this side pawn this bishop pawn for
a center pawn and in exchange
white will normally get a lead in
development with knight to d4
however in the check over white
captures on d4 with the queen
so here after queen takes this does
invite
a few different moves from black the
most
obvious one is knight to c6 and the idea
behind this
is you are attacking the queen with
tempo
now this is an idea that you see a lot
in the scandinavian with the colors
reversed is when the queen is developed
in the center like this
it can get bounced around a bit by black
developing their pieces
and we're going to look at a few lines
here but knight c6 is the main line i
want to cover
some of the sidelines before we get into
uh the main course of the evening
so after queen takes d4 what other moves
are there for black besides knight to c6
there's a couple different options but
the main ones
being pawn to a6 bishop to d7
and knight to f6 and each one has their
own
points so uh with
bishop to d7 we'll start with this one
uh they are preparing to play knight to
c6 with a real tempo
if they don't play bishop to d7 first if
they go knight to c6 in the main line
it can be met with bishop to b5 and
after
the pin is broken we see a trait of
pieces
now if black is trying to avoid these
exchanges bishop d7 first
makes quite a bit of sense here as after
knight to c6 attacking the queen
you no longer have bishop to b5 so let's
make some uh
some passing move here and if black
plays knight c6
again you no longer have bishop to b5 as
this knight is no longer pinned you just
lose your queen
so you should not play that as white
but the um not refutation but the
continuation here for white
is pretty familiar to sicilian players
who play the meroxy bind against the
uh accelerated dragon here so we go
c4 and you're going to see
some natural development from both sides
here knight to c6 attacking the queen
and really the only odd looking move
here is
queen to d2 now this move
was a little confusing to me at first as
i was looking through
my databases because you're blocking the
bishop
you're blocking squares that your
knights can go to
but eventually it will start to make
some sense
normally uh in these types of setups
white is not
trying to go bishop to e3 like a normal
meroxy
a lot of the time we're going to see
white play pawn to b3 and put the bishop
on b2 and the reason this is is because
with this pawn on d6
a easy way for black to develop their
bishop
is to go g6 and bishop g7 so it would be
nice for white if they can get some
opposition
on this diagonal
so here um after queen to d2
there's two main options by black here
we will start with
knight to f6 as i believe this is the
most played move
uh and here we're going to follow a bit
of the game
tierra kove versus fmenko
from alushina 2002
so knight to c3 g6
pawn to h3 stopping any possible uh
pieces coming to g4 bishop to
g7 bishop to d3 castle castle and queen
a5 so queen a5 is going to be another
common move we see here from
black and now we get queen to e2
so queen to e2 has a couple purposes
here first off
um with this queen being protected by
the knight you don't really have any
um in between moves like knight to d5
trying to take on e7 because if
knight d5 uh you can you can take the
queen if you take on e7 the knight
takes or you know there's no real attack
here
uh with the knight on c6 so queen to e2
is looking to break this kind of not
really a pin
because queens are equal but we'd rather
keep our queen and build our chances for
later
and try and make the claim that black's
queen is misplaced here on the queen
side
black will normally play a6 here
and then bishop d2 follows so this is
one of those situations where with the
green on a5 it makes sense to put the
bishop on d2
now moves like knight d5 are again a bit
more attractive
but it's not like you're going to be
winning on e7 again right on c6
um and in this particular game black
transferred the queen to the king side
um and then white uh just tries to
improve the queen by getting on to uh
open squares and then rather than
allow queen to g5 forcing a queen trade
black goes back to c5 and they would
rather have a trade
on this side of the board try and make
the pawn structure a bit more
symmetrical
try and get rid of this uh asymmetry
so we see a queen trade bishop to e3
hitting the pawn
pawn to b6 defending and i think here
i can i can call it here
uh white is going to be uh better here
because of the pawn structure again this
uh
this c4 and e4 is very strong against a
lot of these um
i guess accelerated dragon type setups
um but it's not like it's going to be an
easy win white's still going to have to
maneuver pieces and work
for the win but it's going to be very
hard for black
to advance and break through meanwhile
white is always threatening moves like
e5 which might tickle black's pieces
into poor positions later
which is actually what happened in this
game but i'm going to switch over to
one of our other variations here because
i feel this is where it starts to branch
off
is uh rather than knight to f6
where it is hitting the pawn um and then
followed by knight c3
black can also opt to go g6 right away
and this is just trying to get this set
up as fast as possible
now rather than rush knight to c3
yes is going to be the movie play later
but we're going to play bishop e2
first trying to castle as soon as
possible
and after bishop g7 we see white
castle uh knight to f6 attacking the
pawn
and now we get knight to c3 castles from
black
and now with white to move here in this
position
one common idea you will see is rook
to b1 and this move was seen in the game
anand kasparov in moscow 1995.
and here rook b1 the idea is you're
getting ready to push your pawn
either all the way up to b4 or really
just breaking any kind of problems you
may have after b3
and this knight moves this pin on the
knight can be rather strong
so you just play rook to b1 supporting
both of those ideas getting ready to
play b3 and fiancado or
getting ready to play b4 and push it all
the way up the board
we see black play pawn to a6 in this
game
and white decides to settle on the pawn
b3 idea getting ready to feed keto
and this is also really nice that the
rook is on b1 because not only does it
break this um this potential pin
um but whenever this bishop goes to b2
it's actually over protected and our
queen can move around in the future
um so we can have our queen as an
attacking piece while our rook
defends the bishop uh so queen a5 here
again we see this kind of again not a
pin
but if you move the knight there will be
a queen trade
um and bishop to b2 this is just over
defending the knights getting ready to
move the queen in the future
you see rook f2c8 this is a very common
move you'll see in a lot of dragons
rook f2 d1 and bishop to g4
now uh again we'll see some more
standard moves like queen to e3 and
knight d7
knight d7 is going to be um i guess d7
is going to be the square that this
knight goes to the most
and it's really just to open up the
bishop and get control on
e5 and c5 um
sandra shaq is in the chat with a
question about the bishop d7 line
after g6 queen d2 and then
something to h6 i can't tell if it's
bishop to h6 or if
it's pawn because uh lh6
isn't algebraic notation that i'm
familiar with
but we'll get into it if you can clarify
that last move i'll i'll look into it
but again knight d7 is going to be the
idea of opening up
the position and this knight getting
ready to go to either e5 or c5 but
normally i think it goes to e5 just
because you want to keep as few pieces
on the c
file as possible as uh black would
really like to open that up one day
so in this game you see something like
knight to d5 you see a trade of bishops
bishop tape on f3 bishop take on f3 and
e6
and uh knight c3 and here is where i'm
going to
stop going through the game because i
feel like this is where it starts
turning into the middle game
and here it was a uh
pretty uh rough ending for uh
kasparov after this game uh ananda just
kind of
kind of blew him out of the water over
the next few moves
um okay so sandro shock said after
bishop
2 d7 after c4
g6 and
queen d2 uh
something to h6
uh an idea for black to exchange the
dark square bishop so bishop
h6 i'm assuming here um
this could be an idea but the next
question is
if queen to d2 is the best move
in this move order uh i don't think i
covered g6
but uh here actually after g6 it just
hangs the rook
um silly me to just miss it
but um yeah you can't uh you can't just
play
g6 this early that is why black play
something like knight c6 first and then
after queen d2 if you go
g6 this is that other line we were just
looking at
bishop to e2 bishop to g7 now if you go
bishop
h6 trying to trade the bishops uh
i just want to say i do not think this
is a good move
at all um trying to trade off the dark
square bishops because with this
fiancado structure if you trade off this
bishop
you're going to have a lot of holes on
the dark squares in your position
and if you know anything about the
sicilian dragon
um that piece is your best your best
minor piece
sometimes even being worth up to a rook
this
bishop on the long diagonal is super
strong i don't know why you would go out
of your way to
try and trade off the pieces because
here after something like
just queen c2 and if you go through with
your plan and knight f6
knight c3 just to defend the pawn i
i don't know what you've gained out of
this i don't know why it's so important
to trade off the dark square bishops
but it's still good you brought it up as
as an
idea so
that kind of covers this um knight c6
idea after the the
queen moves we covered g6 here um
and this is really the the main ideas of
bishop d7 is going to resemble a
accelerated dragon
with the meroxie bind
than bishop d7 i did say we had a couple
other moves here
i'm going to look at knight f6 now and
this avoids exchanges
and continues to develop so
again if you go knight c6 just bishop b5
and you're exchanging at least one set
of minor pieces
these sidelines are what black is going
to be looking at in order to try and
avoid exchanges
you want to try and keep as many pieces
on the board to retain
maximum chances but here after knight f6
i think white is just going to be fine
with knight
to c3 defending the pawn
you can try c4 in this position but um
i think there's a weird move order thing
where um
the queen's placement is going to be
rather odd so the line i have here is
knight to c6 attacking the queen
and you no longer have queen to d2 as
that would hang the e4 pawn so you have
to go queen e3
and after queen e3 black just continues
with their normal development
again we see h3 to stop any pieces
coming to g4
and after bishop d7 sorry g7
knight c3 castles bishop e2 black has
queen to b6 offering a queen trade
and this is because the queen had to go
to e3 to defend the pawn rather than go
to d2
black can offer this trade of queens and
while taking may look good at first
because you're doubling the pawns
after bishop e3 and knight d7
uh white's queen side starts to look a
little unstable as the bishop is staring
down the diagonal
this rook is looking at a2 knight is
ready to hop into b4
i don't think that um that this
is the best continuation for white just
because i i think the queen side is a
little
dubious here so rather than trade queens
you should just
castle and then after knight d7 um
i think that this position is just fine
for black they have
excuse me they have the queen trade
whenever uh they want
um and you really don't get that time to
develop on the queen side
like you would like to um mainly
uh this is all just coming from that
pressure on e4 so
rather than spend the time to play c4
and then get hit by the knight right
away and you're falling behind in time
you want to play knight to c3 that way
after
knight to c6 while this here transposes
into the main line after bishop to b5
uh bishop d7 takes takes this is a main
line here
um so we're probably not going to see
knight c6 here actually on the queen
if black is playing this sideline
they're more likely to play something
like
pawn to a6 because if you're going to
transpose to the main line why not just
play the main line
and after a6 white has this kind of
breaking freeing move pawn to e5
so this is hitting the d pawn and the
knight and after
knight to c6 hitting both there's
queen to a4 now this is kind of um
it's not really upon sacrifice it looks
like you're giving up the pawn
but the queen is actually pinning the
knight
so here uh i see someone in the chat
asking what's
wrong with e5 uh if you're asking what's
wrong with e5 for white i don't think
this is wrong
i just went into this line saying i
think this is the best continuation if
you're asking why not e5 for black here
instead of a6 um
here you develop with tempo
and i don't know just retreat the queen
to safety
but uh i'm not sure what side you're
asking for
um but okay e5 for white just kind of
hitting black's position the queen gets
hit you pin the knight
again this pawn is not actually hanging
because after
the pawn takes there is actually knight
e5 because this knight is
pinned cannot move
so yeah okay
uh just some clarification for the e5
move just a second ago it was
for black uh okay wins more space for
black
we'll get into it later let's try and
stick
for the comments in the chat let's try
and stick to the line that uh
i'm currently on because i don't want to
keep jumping back and forth
um at the end i i do ask for questions
uh if we don't touch your line we can
answer it then
um but okay at the 95 bishop d7 is a
must because you need to break the pin
and here white just wins the bishop pair
after knight d7 and queen d7
now bishop b5 is a move i would expect
from the 1200 to 1500 crowd they're
saying hey
i'm trying to attack you and look you
cannot take because if you take i win
your rook
but this move is really um not
accomplishing much
for whites there's actually this move
rook to c8
defending the knight again and after
this
i mean you're not going to benefit from
giving up the bishop pair you just won
your best just to go bishop to e2 and
you've kind of wasted this time
it really let black play rook to c8 for
free
which is a move they would like to play
anyway so i do not recommend going
bishop to b5
no matter how creative it looks i am
going to recommend
just bishop to d2 and it's important
it's bishop to d2 instead of bishop to
e3
bishop to e3 has been played almost as
much in this position
but the key difference is while this
looks like more of a passive square
you retain the option to castle which is
probably going to be more important
than however much more active your
bishop is going to be on e3
because you can castle and then play
bishop e3 you can't go bishop e3 and
castle with the queen on d7
so that is why uh bishop d2 instead of
bishop e3 in this position here
uh something bishop b5 for this
psychological advantage
i guess but um i don't recommend it
we see castles uh queen d4 and now we
see bishop e3
so this uh kind of improving idea that i
just mentioned
and the game here that you want to check
out for
this line is mufian
uh versus duda in
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
but uh mo
sevzian duda 2016.
um both 26 uh 100 level players strong
2600's
playing this position out you see a
queen trade
knight d5 bishop c5 um
a couple bishop trades here offering to
trade the knights
and you get this very interesting uh
bishop and
knight and game here and this game
ended with white winning
but uh that was more due to technique
later on not that this position
is just winning for white but i would
highly recommend checking
that game out
okay um other than bishop d2
i don't think there's any other serious
tries again bishop e3 has been played
almost as much but you don't get a
just castle on the queen side
um i think someone was just saying after
queen to d4 here you should take the
queen but
i don't see why white should
take the time to go out of their way and
capture the queen
yes they can take and knight takes back
and bishop d3 is a fine move
but uh bishop to e3 with the tempo while
you have it
and it's not like your positions garbage
after your knights on a4 you're using
this knight on a4 to support a trade of
dark squared bishops
which is probably going to benefit white
more than black
as white will still have a bishop on the
board
and theoretically this bishop should be
a really good minor piece for black as
it is on the opposite color
of these pawns so
i would say go bishop e3 first and get
the tempo while you can
and then after the trade you'll you'll
be doing fine
okay um other than d takes e5
another move that has been played um
quite a lot actually at
a higher level has been knight to g4
your knight is attacked you go knight to
g4
and it looks like you can take it with
the queen but
you don't want to forget these pieces on
the back rank can still
influence the position and this is where
the other idea of e5 comes in
is that you can capture on e6 and hear
the best move is capture with queen
you don't want to take with pawn because
this pawn being isolated will become a
target in the future
so just take with queen retain your pawn
structures flexibility
and now after h3 uh you don't want uh
white to be having any kind of uh play
here on the king side you just kick the
knight away
knight goes to e5 you see a trade on e5
and while this track looks scary just
bishop to e2 and your problems are
no more bishop f5 is most played here
uh and the idea is basically if white
plays a normal move like castles
they'll play e6 and develop naturally
um but here is a an instance where
whites can play pawn to g4 and be
completely fine the bishop goes back to
d7
bishop to e3 you no longer want to
castle on the king side because you've
extended these pawns
you want to castle queen side and get
this rook on the open file
so now after e6 castle's queen side this
position
is better for whites i can say that
confidently
you have a bishop pair that is doing a
pretty good job at watching the queen
side
your knight is watching over the center
you already have a rook on an open file
and black is struggling to get this
bishop out and castle
at the same pace that um that white has
been developing
sorry i did not mean to make that move
there
um but yeah i also wanted to point that
out with knight g4
this is another idea white can just
remember play pawn g4 later
excuse me okay
so let's go back and we will
see um that kind of covers knight to f6
here now we're going to look at the the
last little sideline
pawn to a6 and pawn to a6
also has this idea of stopping
um exchanges this move stops
bishop to b5 so knight c6 can come with
tempo
now with a6 it is a bit of a slower move
it's not developing any pieces and white
already has two pieces developed
so here you actually do have the time to
continue this
meroxybind type position with c4
and you're not going to run into like
huge problems like you would with knight
f6 because with knight f6
uh it added pressure to your position
immediately
a6 is just um saying okay i don't want
you doing this but you're not putting
extra pressure on the position
so you do have the time for c4 here
and now black is most likely to play
knight to c6
okay your queen is attacked what should
you do
well here um i want to double check
queen d2 queen d2 is still fine here and
you can continue with the ideas that we
had earlier
but uh the game i had here um
i didn't recommend queen d2 because
there was a game
between carlson and jones gawain jones
uh london 2012 which i thought was
pretty recent
magnus was already 28.50 at this time
and he played queen to e3 and i really
just suggested this line because
magnus played it can't be bad um and
it's an easy game to
for you guys to look up if you want to
look into deeper
but here black continues with this
dragon type
setup it's more of like a dragon dorf
now because a6 has been played
and white gets a miracy set up here
we see h3 bishop g7 bishop e2 knight f6
knight c3 hopefully these moves are
looking pretty natural by now
castle castle knight d7 and rook
to b1 again trying to go for this b4
idea
and here again b3 and and fianco is fine
but i think here in this specific
position
you're going to be trying to go for this
um pawn b4 idea
a little bit more as if they play a5
trying to stop this
it opens up the b5 square for the knight
now you don't
necessarily want to go there right away
you can play b3 first but uh
this b5 square does become an outpost
uh and then here something like knight
c5 bishop b2
um and then here gawain jones decided to
play
f5 but uh i think i'm just going to
leave it here and if you want to see
what happens after f5 definitely go
check out
that game again that game is
carlson jones london 2012.
uh and that that kind of covers this a6
idea
there hasn't really been any deviation
from it
um i guess the other idea is that after
a6 you can still play knight c3 and this
is actually the most played move
but the database stats actually show
that this does not score too well for
whites black actually scores much better
here
after knight to c3 um i'm not really
sure
why that is as it seems the moves are
pretty consistent with what white
normally plays but here um we do see
this
e5 idea that someone in the chat was uh
trying to bring up earlier was um they
can try
e5 and there they made the claim that
this
this gains more space for black which i
do agree with
it does game them more space but this
also runs into the same
problem that you run into in the night
or with e5
is that this d6 pawn actually becomes
a huge weakness um that white can pile
up on later so
obviously they can't do anything about
it now but after they save the queen and
develop
further they're going to have a target
that they can pile up on for pretty much
the entire game
so um that that is also true
for e5 and the other line that it was
being suggested for is that anytime
black plays e5
you're going to continue this um
standard theoretical plan
of piling up on d6 and trying to do
something about it
with perfect play black will be able to
hold it's not like d6
you play e5 and d6 is for sure falling
but that's where white is going to be
piling up the pressure
and uh i guess some further moves here
bishop e3 knight a5
attacking the queen again queen to b6
and queen takes bishop takes knight c6
this
position is um fairly balanced i think
white white does get a bit of an upper
hand after castles again just putting on
the pressure early
but no serious winning advantage here
black still has normal developing moves
like rook c8
or i guess uh if you try
bishop to e7 this is where it can go
wrong because bishop c7 and
there there's really no great way to
protect d6
which is why you see rook c8 first um
but then you'll see moves like bishop e7
and castle like normal
so that is the other alternative that
white has is knight to c3 but
i personally don't like this line as it
seems that uh after
black bounces uh or sorry uh
tempo is the queen um i mean
one two three
four queen moves until it's traded off
you're investing a lot of moves into
this piece
now your position is ahead in
development so it's not like it's
completely bad i mean people play this
line for a reason but that's just
why i personally wouldn't play this line
is i feel like you're giving up too much
time with the queen
and that covers pretty much a6
okay so now we've covered all these side
lines
for black now let's get into the main
line the main line knight
c6 attacking the queen right away
uh and as i mentioned earlier the main
move
is bishop to b5 there are two
alternatives here
that you do see um at higher levels you
see queen to a4 and queen to e3 will
cover queen to a4 as it's a little bit
more dubious
because black gets a knight f6 after
knight c3
protecting bishop d7 um first
the database uh statistics that i have
show that white has had particularly
poor results after this move
and i think it takes a lot of courage to
play this position
when your queen does not have many
squares this
uh bishop move does hit the queen and
again you're gonna
you're gonna end up making a lot of
moves with the queen that i particularly
am not a fan of
but other than uh queen to a4 there is
queen to e3
which i've actually seen quite a bit um
i have a couple opponents who play the
check over against me
at the chess club during tournaments and
i think i i personally see queen e3 more
than i see bishop to b5
um but knight f6 bishop to e2 g6
all this normal developing moves
shouldn't be a problem
for either side the key difference in
this position versus the others
is that white has not had the time to
put in c4
so black may have the opportunity to do
a little bit more stuff on the queen
side here
see uh rook to d1 knight d7 again this
knight maneuver to open up the bishop
this also stops
bishop to d2 from being played as bishop
takes b2 and then the rook
so knight c3 pawn to b6 rook b1
and bishop to b7 and i'm going to cut
the analysis of this line
here but i should also mention the name
of this system with queen e3 i forgot to
mention earlier
is known as the hari krishna system
as grand master hari krishna has been
bringing this to light recently
and there was actually a game played
this year on lee chess
between hari krishna and um actually
the 2021 world championship
candidate yan nepam nishi
so uh definitely check out these games
these are being played at the very top
level between
27 28 hundreds
um let's see we're getting someone in
the chat saying
in this line you prefer the queen side
castle
i don't know how i feel about that how
are you actually
going to do that because
all these moves i guess after queen e3
why would you try and queenside castle
if it takes three moves
uh versus two moves on the king side
um so if you'd like to follow up your
idea
go right ahead um but
you're talking about preferring the
queenside castle and damage the kingside
pawn structure when realistically it
takes a lot of time to do that this is
not your standard dragon
where you can just develop normally and
just shove the h pawn down the board
because you're gonna have to play moves
like knight c3 bishop d2 castle's queen
side and then not only that you're gonna
have to try and move this knight out of
the way so you can get
extra power from the f and g pawns so
if you would like to give me specific
moves of how you're going to make this
work
i'll be very interested we'll go over it
but i don't think white has the time to
do all these things you're hoping for
um okay so that is the hari krishna
system
which is uh rising in popularity for
sure the
main line through the test of time
though has been bishop to b5
and this is just pinning the knight
stopping it from attacking the queen
now here um pretty much a uh
not mandatory move i mean queen c7 i
guess is a sideline but bishop d7
is definitely the most principle
um let's see uh okay they're responding
about their uh
system in the uh hare krishna line and
they're just asking what is the threat
for black
black doesn't need to make threats um
you know they just develop normally it's
too early in the game to say that
there's big
threats but if you're playing chess
looking for a threat on every single
move you're going to be missing a lot of
the positional
features as well but i mean if the best
defense to your idea is
what is their threat um i'm sorry that
that is not a strong enough argument for
me
back to the main line um white does
exchange here they give up the bishop
pair um in order to leave the queen
in the center now a lot of times
at scholastic tournaments i have seen um
players end up playing um g6 soon so
like
knight c3 uh and unfortunately at my
very first ever tournament
i ended up playing g6 in this position
and hung a rook
please do not play g6 and hang a rook
here
um g6 is just uh not good
not good enough so after knight c3 you
play knight f6
closing off this diagonal now g6 is a
possibility
uh and bishop to g5 so bishop to g5
while it's not a pin
does set yourself up for one e6 is a the
main line here
if they try and go g6 then this trade is
good for
white as this pawn is now isolated
so they should go e6 if they're trying
to develop the dark square bishop
and this is just a pretty healthy place
to put the bishop if you're trying to
castle queenside
so pawn e6 here and castles and now we
see that d6
is a bit of a weakness again and we see
bishop to e7
now this is another kind of branching
point for the checkover there's a couple
sidelines that white has we're going to
be looking at the main move rook
h to e1 queen to d3 has a couple moves
i'll show
and then um it looks like bishop to d2
has been played but i i'm not a big fan
of bishop to d2 because you're
undeveloping
um and then the other move in this
position
um one of the first games i looked at
when i was preparing this is bishop
takes
f6 and this was seen in feingold
esserman in 2012 or 2013.
um where after the bishop takes back
black
sacrifices this pawn um you're not
really sacrificing the pawn as after
bishop c3
bc3 bishop takes e4
but this end game is rather interesting
for both sides
something like knight e5 um
and they don't want to take on g2 as
rook g1 enters the position
but that is also a very interesting game
to look at and ben feingold actually has
his commentary on his own youtube
channel
over that game but that is a very rare
sideline only played about 20
25 times um someone's asking if white
can play e5 before castling here so
bishop g5
e6 and then rather than castle play e5
here
um that's a good question
i think if my opponent played e5
i i would not be against this as i can
take
you have to do something for your queen
if you go
queen e5 you can no longer castle
queenside
so i'm not too worried about this and
bishop d6 comes with tempo on the queen
right away
um and if you trade queens i'm very
happy taking with the rook because now
my rook's on an open file i didn't have
to do anything
um if 95 getting your pawn back
bishop g2 looks to be the case
so uh at least from black's point of
view i wouldn't have any problem with
white playing this as i can just take
and then i guess if you're playing this
as white you have to take on e5 with the
queen
but i don't like the idea of black
getting this file after any of these
variations so i would stay away from e5
and see if you can time it see if
there's a better time to play it later
on
um just castle first build up this
pressure on
on the d file maybe then e5 can be more
appropriate as you have another
attacker on the d file but
as any chess game it's all subject to
circumstance
um and here bishop e7 and
let's see one move here that has been
played is queen to d3
uh and here queen to a5 is a common move
where it is attacking the bishop on g5
it is defended by the knight though but
after something like h4
h6 and then bishop takes is completely
fine here
um black is not actually hanging this
pawn as something like a
oh what is it bishop c3 ruining the king
side structure i was looking also at
rook
d8 isn't too terrible for black here
um so you can take if you want
but uh that's kind of with this queen d3
you're going to be looking at trading
and going from there you're going to
have two knights against two bishops
which you play that if you like your
knights i guess
uh but i think i i like just the main
move here rook h
to e1 this here is the main line
um see more comments about the e5 move
yeah i don't know it's all good um but
okay rook h to e1 here as the main move
and black really should castle here um
castle get the king to safety getting
ready to bring your rook to the center
and here after castles the most played
move is king to b1
uh after king to b1 there's two options
for black there is queen to a5
and there is h6 we'll look at queen to
a5 real quick as this is less played
but after queen to a5 there's this move
queen to d2
which i think is very interesting as
after queen d2 there
is a threat of knight d5 where after
knight d5 you're going to take on e7
and black is going to lose their bishop
pair
and let's say that okay black plays some
passing move knight d5 and if they try
to trade queens is
losing on the spot after knight e7 so
they have to play something like
um like queen to uh d8
uh if they play some random move here
but
because of this threat queen a6 has been
the main move
um just because knight d5 is a pretty
strong threat with the queen
undefended this is why um it's also
important to make note of if your
opponent has a knight on c6 or not
um because this knight d5 idea is uh
apparent not just in this sicilian
variation but in
a lot of others as well um in the
bind particularly but okay queen a6
knight d4 bringing the knight to the
center hitting the bishop getting ready
to play f3
rook f2 ch is a natural developing move
f3 and bishop
to e8 opening up the file for the rook
and now after g4 rook c4
h4 all these are fine moves the game
here
is um zigalco versus
vorobiov in party vice 2006
that is the game here um that i followed
i think here after h4
you start to run into more standard
sicilian themes
of um pushing on the king side stopping
white on the queen side and this is what
um
our friend fetty in the chat was hoping
for in some other lines
but here after queen a5 this is a pretty
good plan as it starts to mirror
more regular open sicilians because you
do get to play
knight d4 in time
all because you get this kind of tempo
with this knight d5 threat
other than queen a5 the main move here
is
h6 and after h6 it's attacking the
bishop you have to do something about
this bishop
um and here's one of the positions where
you can bring it back
so bishop h4 you don't really want to
make this
trade here as bishop f6 tempos the queen
you can take on d6 if you want but black
is not obligated to take back they can
go queen b6 and now they're already
having
threats to win the night they're ready
to bring their rooks into the center
so um here while this is possible it is
playable
i don't think i recommend this i think
it gives black a little bit more
chances for counter play than i am
comfortable with
so um after h6 just bring the bishop
back to
h4 um you don't want to
take and allow the bishop to be staring
at the king's side
and here rookie 8 has been played many a
time
um really uh i don't
completely understand this move uh i
know that this
exists in the dragon as well this rookie
8 move
um but i i honestly
cannot tell you the purpose of this move
i'm assuming it's just to uh
help strengthen your your center in the
near future
bishop to g3 has been played
um i think h3 is also a recommendation
here but i think
um bishop g3 i'm just gonna recommend
that
to uh keep things simple you're
attacking d6
and uh the game this is from is actually
um following svidler kasparov in 1999
so another game with strong players and
here
kasparov ended up playing d5 which is a
type of pawn sacrifice
now it might not seem apparent right
away that this is a sacrifice
um here after d5
let's talk about how this is a sacrifice
you go with e5
attacking the knight and after 94 you
trade
now here in the game this is where um
fiddler he didn't mess up here but after
trading on d8
um black really doesn't have any
problems here
they have the bishop pair which in
this scenario is kind of worth giving up
this pawn um
which isn't even really given up right
away again it's just this e4 pawn
for black is um just really weak they
can never play f5
and white really is just waiting for the
right time to take on e4 they can't go
right away because um
bishop c6 might be a problem the knight
on d4
kind of helps with that but uh i mean if
you take bishop c6 and you can't take on
c6 because you hang your rook on d1
so and the problem with allowing bishop
to c6 is that it's skewers to get the
pawn on g2 so you're not really winning
this pawn you're just
got to play it slow patient wait to take
at the right time
and uh in the games fiddler chose king
c2 but enough of that game uh
i have my recommendation queen to e3
and this move i think is slightly better
um you get a tempo on their queen and
after queen a5
you go knight to d2 and
the idea here is now this pawn looks
like it's actually falling
um this knight is going to take the take
with the bishop you're good to take back
with the queen
um and this is probably how i would
continue but
here engines are giving triple zeros
uh i think it's unclear who is better
because white is going to go up this
pawn
in turn black has the bishop pair and
rather easy development
so i think this is a position that i
would love to see played out
um but i i
i don't see it happening anytime in the
immediate future as i don't think many
people are playing the check over
variation now but
i think everyone's kind of gravitating
toward this uh
was the the hard krishnan system uh
yeah hari krishna system is uh what
people are starting to gravitate towards
but
this is what i would like to see played
out one day and we'll see if it ever
happens
but that is all of the
the games the lines the theory that i
have put together for you guys hopefully
you guys found this helpful
i know that finding theory for the check
over can be
uh pretty difficult like i said is
pretty difficult for me
um my copy of the mco i couldn't even
find this opening in there um
so again hopefully this helps if there's
any questions on specific
lines this time is for you we have five
minutes before the
end of our scheduled time here so if
anybody has any other questions on any
specific
lines and positions now's your time put
it in the chat
um okay let's see freddy's asking more
questions
what if he plays g6 so in this main line
what if they tried g6
um
when would they be playing g6 is my
question
because if you play e6 you have to go
bishop e7
otherwise uh if you try playing g6 after
the knight is going to hang
or you're gonna have some big weaknesses
on the king's side so if you try g6
right away
i also covered this already is uh the
bishop takes
and while these doubled pawns aren't
horrible for black you can play with
this
um you have a decision to make if you go
bishop g7 which makes a lot of sense
d6 is pretty weak and i'm not sure
how good it is for black to try and mix
these ideas
um
okay someone's suggesting to do the
english
another person suggesting to do the
traxler i'm not taking opening
suggestions
at this current point in time if you
have an opening you want to see um
please come back to the video once it's
published to youtube and put it in the
comments
not gonna lie i forget your guys's
suggestions if it's just in the chat
like this
i want to make sure that i can get to
them make sure i have them
so in the comments section after this
video is published is the best place to
put your opening suggestions
ah okay clarification
uh they were saying after they kicked
the bishop with h6 why don't they play
g5
well in this specific scenario um
without doing any any calculation
into it um g5 looks rather weakening
to me because the king has already
castled
if the king had not castled i think this
is uh more playable
but because the king is already castled
i'm trying to already figure out why
moves like knight g5 or bishop g5
um wouldn't work here but
aside from those sacrifices i think i
can just go bishop g3
hit d6 again and then claim that your
king side is over
extended in the long run um
i don't know what you play here i guess
you can try and play
excuse me e5 and try and shut down this
diagonal
but the queen comes to e3 and now knight
g5
queen g5 is trying to at least secure a
draw i think
um knight d5 is also coming
so i think the the problem with g5 is
you're just over extending and g5
becomes a target and can be the subject
of possible sacrifices
that's not a guarantee but that is my
best guess
as to why g5 is not good
and then uh just declare or back that
claim up i also do have stockfish 13
running
uh and it's saying after bishop g3 the
position is plus one and a half
so um just over extending the pawns in
front of the king
general uh is a general no no you don't
want to be pushing the pawns in harvard
king
that far forward but it was a good
question
any other questions about the check over
or lines that come from
got about another minute here
so got time for one more question if
anyone has them
hey fetty the the pleasure is all mine i
love giving these lectures for you guys
you guys have been very interactive in
the chat with me makes it a great
pleasure
and you do have a lot of great questions
um
i know we were kind of button heads
there a little bit about some some ways
black can handle the position
or or white um but i mean that's that's
the beauty of trust people can have
different opinions on it
um and and really that's what i mean
what we do in tournaments is opinions on
how each side should handle the position
um so if i came off too strong i'm sorry
but uh i do want to say
you had a lot of good questions a lot of
good examples to bring up
so big shout out to fetty has seen there
all right well it is 7 30 so we're going
to wrap things up here on youtube we'll
get this video sent to ben for
editing and like i said if you have
different openings you want to see wait
until the video is published to youtube
for replay
drop it in the comment section there i
always check it out a couple days after
the video to see what you guys are
wanting me to
to show you guys um but now we're going
to like i said end it on youtube we're
going to switch over to twitch where
we're going to continue our winner's
circle series where we're following the
games of vasily smith's love in the 1953
candidates
we're covering rounds 14 15 and 16 today
and let me tell you there is a juicy
game
tonight last week was kind of boring
with it but
uh hop on over to our twitch twitch.tv
st louis trust club and we'll see you
there
thanks for stopping